as president Trump catches heat from all
sides over his decision to move US
troops out of northern Syria we examine
the president's seemingly contradictory
foreign policy impulses and we ask is
there any such thing as the Trump
doctrine then AOC and the rest of the
squad pick a presidential candidate
Kanye West give lessons on Family Values
and finally the mailbag all that more
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have before me the single greatest
letter ever written by a head of state
to another head of state this president
Trump's truly bizarre and very very
entertaining letter to err do on the
president of Turkey we will analyze it
because this letter as well as president
Trump's treatment of Nancy Pelosi as
well as president Trump's treatment of
the late Elijah Cummings who died very
unexpectedly and very sadly just today
they do tell us something about the
Trump doctrine we will connect all of
the dots but first we got to thank our
friends over at Rock Auto oh how I love
Rock Auto Rock Auto is a family business
and they are serving Auto Parts
customers online for 20 years this is
very important I really like Rock Auto
because I don't know anything about cars
and I had car trouble
about a month and a half ago now a month
and I have two months ago and I just
don't know anything about and the
trouble is you go to these car repair
shops and they don't have the part they
don't know they never have the part so
they just go online and then they charge
you a huge markup that's where Rock Auto
comes in you go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
and then they have a bunch of other
things that I've never even heard of
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver you can get everything you
need in a few easy clicks delivered
directly to your door the Rock auto comm
catalog is unique it's remarkably easy
to navigate this is I think the best
part of this site even somebody like me
who does not know anything about
automobiles can go and navigate it
really really easily and it's just
really fair you always get a really fair
price quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle you choose
the brands the specifications the prices
you prefer amazing selection and then
not a lot of gimmicks you know it's just
reliably low prices all the parts you're
called car will ever need Rock Auto calm
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
and then you write knowles canada w in
their camera wles
i know how to spell my name i KN o w how
to spell my name KO w le s in there how
did you hear about a section
and that's how they will know that we
sent you and that's very important
because we appreciate their support and
you're gonna love it you're gonna love
Rock Auto go check it out right now
does President Trump have a coherent
foreign policy doctrine a lot of people
are looking at this recent letter that
he sent to the president of Turkey air
doo-hwan and saying he just he's a
maniac he has no idea what he's doing
he's a complete lunatic he might be a
lunatic but he's crazy as a fox and the
Fox matters here because when we think
about foreign policy there are all sorts
of analogies we use Isaiah Berlin the
philosopher said are you a fox or you a
hedgehog is Trump a realist is he an
internationalist is he a liberal a Xia
this is he that is he this is that I
think that President Trump does have a
coherent foreign policy doctrine his
detractors say he's impetuous and he's
he's Petty and personal and stupid and
ignorant his more charitable distract
detractors say that if Trump does have
any sort of doctrine it's full of
contradictions and paradoxes right it's
so on the one hand he says we're gonna
go kill Isis we're gonna go overseas and
send troops in and kill Isis then he
says we're gonna take all our troops
home we have too many troops abroad on
the one hand he says we want tariffs
tariffs are great tariffs are a great
thing on the other end he says we want
to get rid of all tariffs we want
totally free trade one day he says we
hate China we're going to destroy China
next days congratulating China
uncensored Ixion's I think the doctrine
is a lot more coherent than people think
and you can see it in this absolutely
wild and crazy letter that he sent to
everyone here's the letter this is an
authentic letter he referred to it
yesterday we're going around the
internet dear mr. president let's work
out a great deal exclamation point right
at the beginning completely uncommon
just like you talk to somebody in a bar
let's work out a great deal really
positive is how he starts then he goes a
little negative you don't want to be
responsible for slaughtering thousands
of people and I don't want to be
responsible for destroying the Turkish
economy and I will I've already given
you a little sample with respect to
pastor
Brunson this was another foreign policy
conflict that they
we've had with turkey I've worked hard
to solve some of your problems don't let
the world down you can make a great deal
general [ __ ] is willing to negotiate
with you and he's willing to make
concessions that they would never have
made in the past
I am confidentially enclosing a copy of
his letter to me just received history
will look favorably upon you if you get
this done the right and humane way it
will look upon you forever as the devil
if good things don't happen don't be a
tough guy don't be a fool I will call
you later
sincerely Donald Trump there is so much
in this letter to unpack tells you a lot
about the doctor he starts out let's
make a good deal very positive very
willing to negotiate then he threatens
the the president of Turkey for the rest
of the paragraph then he talks about how
he has worked in Turkey's interest then
he encourages him to make a good deal in
Turkey's own interest then he gives some
evidence of why this is Turk in Turkey's
interest in the enclosed letter that's
confidential then he goes on to talk
about Turkey's interest then he
threatens Turkey and shows why it's not
in their interest to work against the
United States here then he includes that
last bit of advice don't be a tough guy
don't be a fool I will call you later I
think that I think the Trump doctrine
you could sum it up in those three lines
don't be a tough guy don't be a fool I
will call you later what does he mean
don't be a tough guy he doesn't mean
don't be tough Trump talks all the time
about how we need to be tough
Trump has positioned himself as the
tough guy what he means by don't be a
tough guy is don't don't act foolishly
out of a desire to appear tough because
of your pride I think that's what that
really means don't let your pride make
you fall into stupid decisions which he
then reiterates in the next sentence
don't be a fool and in which I think he
then vindicates that interpretation in
the final sentence which is I will call
you later because Trump doesn't let his
pride get in the way of things you know
Trump gets this
knock on him for being prideful and
narcissistic and petty and everything's
about his own ego I I don't think that's
the case I think everything is about his
interest I think he views politics
through the realm not of pride but of
interest I think there's actually a
profound humility in viewing politics
through that realm of interest I mean if
if Trump had real pride here what would
he do
he'd go in and blow Turkey off the map
he'd glass the whole country right he'd
take out the Turkish military he'd say
don't you dare do this we're gonna get
you this is the this is the credibility
of the United States on the line he's
not doing that he's saying let's make a
deal okay you did something I don't like
we'll make a deal though
that requires a certain humility and and
not allowing pride to make you prefer to
appear like a tough guy than to actually
cut some sort of deal there's a lot more
to this doctrine but I think it actually
can be distilled into some pretty clear
points how does it compare with other
doctrines Ronald Reagan had a doctrine
Reagan's doctrine was in part written by
Charles Krauthammer in an essay that
Krauthammer wrote in in part not to even
observe the Trump the Reagan doctrine
but to write the Reagan doctrine
Krauthammer a cop to this later on he
said I I wasn't sure what sort of
foreign policy was going on here
but I figured I could encourage the
White House to follow my foreign policy
and Reagan then articulated this
doctrine at his State of the Union
address he said quote freedom is not the
sole prerogative of a chosen few it is
the universal right of all God's
children
he said America's mission is to quote
nourish and defend freedom and democracy
he said quote we must stand by our
Democratic allies and we must not break
faith with those who are risking their
lives on every continent from
Afghanistan to Nicaragua to defy soviet
supported aggression and secure rights
which have been ours from birth support
for freedom fighters is self-defense
now this doctrine the Reagan doctrine
has been knocked because we ended up
supporting people in the Middle East who
them turned out to be not so favorable
to us twenty or thirty years later we
supported people who were Islamists who
supported political Islam and who now we
would we would describe as terrorists so
he gets hit for that
the that that I don't think is a
legitimate criticism the Reagan doctrine
made perfect sense within the context of
the Soviet Union it was in the national
interest of the United States to consult
can constrain Soviet expansion to
constrain communism and so that is what
we did we did this by advocating a
policy of liberal internationalism we
did this by advocating a policy of
freedom as the birthright of all people
around the world and this particular
American conception of freedom and we
were going to stop the Soviet Union
which we did and it worked
that's the vindication of the Reagan
doctrine the Berlin Wall came down the
Reagan doctrine worked what was the Bush
Doctrine the Bush Doctrine was in many
ways the extension of the Reagan
doctrine in a world outside of the Cold
War this made less sense because
politics is contextual politics is about
interest during the Cold War we could
easily identify the interests of the
United States with the Reagan doctrine
after the Cold War liberal
interventionists lost sight of this key
feature which is what is in the American
national security interest and in the
national interest broadly what liberal
interventionists at that time said was
it was in the interest of the United
States to have broad sort of liberal
Empire that would create Madisonian
ideas of freedom all throughout the
world in places and in contexts that did
not have any history of that this
appears not to have worked very well
though they are very similar doctrines
the context is what's different the
interest is what's different and the
Trump doctrine is a repudiation of the
Bush Doctrine now there are other
components of this too you know
president Trump spelled this out in a
pretty nuanced statement he gave on
Syria he's been relatively mum on his
decision to pull out of Syria as all of
the left and half of the right are
furious with him over pulling troops out
of northern Syria he made a statement in
the White House yesterday which was
actually quite nuanced that the
statement he made on Syria explained
his foreign policy vision as a vision of
interest and nationalism areas now
President Aaron's decision didn't
surprise me because he's wanted to do
that for a long time he's been building
up troops on the border with Syria for a
long time as you know our soldiers are
mostly gone from the area we only had 26
28 but under 50 we think it's probably
28 but under 50 soldiers and which is a
very tiny force and it didn't surprise
me at all this is they've been warring
for many years it's unnatural for us but
it's sort of natural for them they fight
and they fight long and they fight hard
and they've been fighting Syria for a
long time and on the border that's the
border with Syria and I say why are we
protecting Syria's land Assad's not a
friend of ours why are we protecting
their land and Syria also has a
relationship with the Kurds who by the
way are no angels okay who is an angel
there aren't too many around but Syria
has a relationship with the Kurds so
they'll come in for their border and
they'll fight they may bring partners in
they could bring Russia in and I say
welcome to it Russia went into
Afghanistan when it was the Soviet Union
and it became Russia became a much
smaller country because of Afghanistan
you can overextend you can do a lot of
things but frankly if Russia is going to
help in protecting the Kurds that's a
good thing that a bad thing
this is an astounding statement because
it shows a level of nuance that I think
a lot of people didn't think that Trump
had my position on the decision to move
50 or so troops out of Syria out of
northern Syria is basically that the
issue is much more complicated than
anyone is would like you to believe
we'll get into that in one second we'll
get into what this means because the the
foreign policy the doctrine the
president from just espoused in that
statement is not some modern new crazy
shoot by the hip thing this is a foreign
policy that goes back to Charles de
Gaulle it goes back to Lord Palmerston
it goes back to George Washington
himself we'll get to that in a second
but first I've got to thank our friends
over at Express vie
p.m. I don't need to tell you how big
tech companies are not particularly
friendly to conservatives is that a big
secret Twitter not the most friendly to
conservatives other big tech companies
too if you can't trust certain elements
in Silicon Valley to treat conservatives
fairly how on earth could you trust them
to handle your privacy and your personal
data online are you gonna do that that
is why you must use Express VPN every
time you go online big tech companies
they can use your IP address to match
your internet activity to your identity
or your location what does that mean
when I use Express VPN search engines
and media sites do not see my IP address
at all that means my identity is masked
and anonymous if you are listening to
this show something tells me you go on
some sort of shady web sites you know
maybe you open up that incognito tab
late at night close the blinds and you
go to websites like you know daily
wire.com
things like things you don't want to get
at it could really mess up some
relationships okay everybody's really
tense right now expressvpn software
takes just a minute to set up on your
computer or on your phone you just tap
one button and you are protected so if
you want to protect your data today if
you think that your internet data belong
to you and not to big tech companies who
are not friendly to conservatives then
expressvpn is the answer protect your
online activity today with the VPN I
trust to keep my data safe expressvpn
comm / michael mi CH AE l to claim an
exclusive offer from my listeners expr
ESS VPN comm / michael you get three
months free with one year package
expressvpn comm / michael to get started
what Trump just said here that the
statement that's really getting people
upset is that the Kurds
all the Kurds are in Angels it's like
he's attacking the Kurds but what he
said to follow up is you don't see a lot
of angels really anywhere James Madison
said this right he said we're not
governed by angels we are not angels
ourselves and the situation in Syria is
complicated the alliances have been
changing rapidly just to give you a
little taste of it until 2017 we
supported the Free Syrian Army then we
stopped supporting the Free Syrian Army
now I suppose we're opposed to the free
Syria
when we tried to go in to fight Isis
when Barack Obama went in in 2014 he
tried to get Turkey which is the second
largest military in NATO to go in with
us Turkey didn't want to go in because
the official policy of the United States
was not regime change in Damascus was
not asking Bashar Assad so we make a
deal not with the Kurds broadly but with
the YPG the people's protection units
which is a group of Kurds this was a
tricky Alliance because the YPG is
associated with the PKK which is the
Kurdistan Workers Party the Kurdistan
Workers Party is officially considered a
terrorist organization by the United
States as well as by the EU in the
United Kingdom and crucially by Turkey
so we make this alliance that's okay
that's fine and we're working with a
common interest to defeat Isis we defeat
Isis now the question is do we privilege
an alliance with a sub-state group of
people the YPG which has an affiliation
with a group that we consider terrorists
at the State Department or do we
privilege a 67-year alliance through
NATO with our NATO ally Turkey which is
a nation-state there's no question about
that
obviously you privilege the relationship
with Turkey Obama would have done it
Trump did it to the same people who are
criticizing President Trump for trying
our allies or also the people who
criticize Trump for undermining NATO but
we chose our NATO ally over our sub
state actor Ally and this was a very sad
situation because we have regularly
abandoned the Kurds we've abandoned the
Kurds in the 1970s when we use them to
stir up trouble against Saddam Hussein
on behalf of the Shah of Iran we
abandoned the Kurds after the Gulf War
in 1991 when we suggested to them that
we would support them in an uprising
against Saddam Hussein we didn't do that
and they got massacred and we've
abandoned groups of Kurds now this
happens regularly so one of the
arguments one of the arguments for the
pulling the troops out of Syria is now
that Bashar Assad is ensconced in power
he's not going to be asked at anytime
soon it is in the Kurds longer-term
interest to strike a deal for some form
of sovereignty and independence with
Bashar Assad rather than to continue the
civil war in a stalemate and try to work
out a in a long term alliance with the
United States which has abandoned them
on
multiple occasions for the last 50 years
I say all of that to say this is a very
complicated situation and what is
Trump's take away from this Trump's take
away from this is nations do not have
permanent friends nations have interests
they don't have permanent friends
certainly with sub state actors they
don't permanent friends with nations
they only have interests some people say
this is cynical and awful and evil and
unamerican BS this is an idea advocated
by Lord Palmerston by Charles de Gaulle
and by George Washington himself George
Washington in his farewell address said
quote it is our true policy to steer
clear of permanent alliance with any
portion of the foreign world why does
that mean we can't have any friends now
of course we can have temporary
alliances but nations have interests not
personal friends then Trump goes on to
caution against the military-industrial
complex we're gonna bring our great
soldiers back home where they belong we
don't have to fight these endless wars
we're bringing it back home that's what
I want on and some people whether it's
you call it the military-industrial
complex or or beyond that they'd like me
to stay one of the problems I have and
one of for instance with a witch-hunt
you have people that want me to stay
they want me to fight forever yeah they
do very well fighting that's what they
want to do fight a lot of companies want
to fight because they make their weapons
based on fighting not based on peace and
they take care of a lot of people I want
to bring our soldiers back home we're
not a police force we're a fighting
force with the greatest fighting force
ever okay so president from warns
against the military-industrial complex
sounds a little bit like a kook like a
conspiracy theory guy with a tinfoil hat
right sort of he also sounds like
President Eisenhower who used that exact
phrase when he was leaving office he
said beware the military-industrial
complex and he sounds a little bit like
Washington who says in void avoid these
permanent alliances sounds like
Jefferson avoid entangling alliances too
then
Trump explains the really tangible
reason why he wants to get the the
soldiers out of Syria and what this
four american grand strategy broadly i
campaigned on bringing our soldiers back
home and that's what i'm doing that
includes other places too many other
places statutorily it takes a period of
time diplomatically it takes a period of
time but you know we're in many
countries many many countries i'm
embarrassed to tell you how many i know
the exact number but i'm embarrassed to
say it because is so foolish we're in
countries were protecting countries that
don't even like us they take advantage
of us they don't pay nothing okay what
President Trump is saying here is not
only are we gonna pull out of Syria I
want to pull out of all these 130
countries that were in around the world
I want to pull out why because he's
defending the Westphalian system the
order of nation-states as opposed to an
imperial order where the United States
acts as a sort of benevolent liberal
Empire around the world I think there
are good arguments for both of those I
think there's a good argument for the
system of nation-states I think there's
a good argument for Empire Trump is
making clear he supports nation-states
and the Westphalian system you even see
this you see you get clues about Trump's
foreign policy the Trump doctrine the
Trump grand strategy in his interactions
even with individuals at home he had
this meeting yesterday with the
Democrats and Nancy Pelosi made a big
scene about it and she stood up and
pointed a finger at Trump so she could
get a picture and put it on Twitter a
Chuck Schumer was crying about this at a
press conference outside because the
most dangerous place in the world is not
in northern Syria it's between Chuck
Schumer and a television camera here's
Chuck Schumer complaining about the
meeting it was insulting particularly to
the speaker she kept her cool complete
but he called her a third-rate
politician he said that the there are
communists involved and you guys might
like that I mean this was not a dialogue
it was sort of a diatribe a nasty diet
rot not focused on the facts
particularly the fact of how to curtail
Isis a terrorist organization that aims
to hurt the United States in our
homeland okay
he says Nancy Pelosi kept her cool she
didn't we have photographic evidence
that she didn't she stood up and wagged
her finger like a lunatic the reason I
bring this up is because President Trump
at different times in his life will say
Nancy Pelosi is the greatest when she
became Speaker of the House he sent her
a note so Nancy you're the greatest
congratulations then he goes and screams
at her on one day he says Ted Cruz is a
liar whose father murdered JFK the next
day said I call him beautiful Ted now
one day he's attacking Rand Paul the
next day he likes Rand Paul one day
you'll remember just a few months ago
Trump was going after congressman Elijah
Cummings as one of the worst most
crooked members of all of Congress then
Elijah Cummings very sadly passed away
today he's only 68 years old very very
young man and we were all nervous the
Trump was gonna say something mean about
him which was just would serve no
purpose at all and would be very
unseemly and he didn't Trump sent out a
tweet he said quote my warmest
condolences to the family and many
friends of Congressman Elijah Cummings I
got to see firsthand the strength
passion and wisdom of this highly
respected political leader his work and
voice on so many fronts will be very
hard if not impossible to replace very
nice note absolutely right he's not
saying that he really likes he lies
you're cuffing us here but he is he's
saying look obviously the guy was strong
stayed in office a long time he was very
passionate there's one of the most
passionate orders in the Congress and he
did have wisdom he had a certainly a lot
of political wisdom and it's sad that he
died so young and president Trump made a
nice note about him people who were more
rigidly ideological who have a little
more a little more I guess you could say
pride or consistency would be another
word would would have stuck to their
guns and said he's a really terrible guy
but it's all contextual for Trump
this gives us some of the Trump doctrine
the keys here are the context
circumstances changing one foreign
policy strategy will not fit for all
times in all places they must be adapted
to different circumstances what worked
in the Cold War will not necessarily
improbably won't work after the Cold War
and the Trump doctrine is one of radical
self-interest so president Trump there's
there's an irony there's a paradox
there's a contradiction on the one hand
everything about him is personal he says
to everyone I'll call you later he says
don't be a tough guy don't be a fool
he's really hitting them really hard but
then he says but don't worry I'll call
you later there's a personal touch to it
because politics has acted out by
persons but you don't take anything
personally even in the same letter he
changes tone like three times he doesn't
take this stuff the attacks he doesn't
take that personally the attacks he
gives he doesn't take that personally he
can switch on a dime and this is
important because what he is taking is
the Charles DeGaulle idea that nations
don't have friends they have interests
he's making that even about himself he's
saying politicians don't have friends
they have interests and so we we work
together when our interests align we
don't work together when our interests
don't align be that the YPG Kurdish
forces be that turkey be that Russia in
the post-cold war world with a rising
China being the number one adversary
maybe you have to change maybe Russia is
no longer a number one geopolitical foe
if China is now our number one pop
geopolitical foe maybe we need to play
Russia off China just as during the Cold
War in the 1970s we played China off of
Russia it's highly contextual it's
strongly based on radical self-interest
and it has the underlying premise that
the system of nation-states is more in
American long-term strategic interest
then a single superpower liberal world
order led by the United States liberal
international Empire that's the premise
and he will follow that to the radical
self-interest of politicians and of the
United States you can disagree with that
but that is a coherent foreign policy
doctrine and if you don't think it's go
here and if you strongly disagree with
it you have to propose an alternative
and when
you propose an alternative then you have
to look not just at the successes but at
the failures of that liberal
internationalism not just the great
successes of the Reagan era but some of
the failures that came afterward we will
get to domestic politics where IOC and
the squad endorsed Bernie Sanders we'll
even get to Kanye West family values and
finally the mailbag but first I got to
thank our friends over at liquid IV oh I
love liquid IV do you know why is liquid
IV is really good for athletes we're
going out there and they're getting
dehydrated because liquid IV is the
fastest most efficient way to stay
hydrated now for me I don't do a whole
lot of athletics that's not not exactly
my mo however occasionally I maybe I'll
go at it night and have a couple Coca
Cola's you know a few adult beverages
now and again with my friends liquid IV
is very good for the morning after as
well if you were trying to drink more
water liquid IV hydrates you two to
three times faster and more efficiently
than water alone it has an added bonus
of vitamins c b3 b5 b6 and b12 so I'm
not going to tell you that I went out
and ran a marathon a couple weeks ago
all right I didn't but I did wake up
feeling a little dehydrated
I will leave it at that had some liquid
IV I felt much much better it really
hydrates you much faster it's the
fastest growing wellness brand you can
find them everywhere even Costco you can
find their hydration multiplier sold at
all Costco's nationwide liquid IV can
provide the same hydration as drinking
two to three bottles of water I love it
I know you will too right now my
listeners get 25% off at liquid IV com
go do it guys I'm telling you whether
you're an athlete you know or you're
sweating a lot doing kind of good
wholesome things or if you were you know
like me on a Friday night
use the code Knowles kinder wles a check
out 25% off anything you order at liquid
Ivy's website liquid IV dot-com enter
promo code Knowles canna wles get your
savings start getting better hydration
it's really really great no one drinks
enough water all I do during the day is
drink coffee and then sometimes at night
oh hi but some adult beverages you need
to hydrate liquid IV com promo code
Knolls KO WLA s don't wait start
hydrating today we have a lot more
coming up we got a OC we got Kanye but
we've got to say goodbye go to daily
wire.com you know what you get 10 bucks
a month hundred dollars for an annual
membership me Andrew
and show ben shapiro show mount wall
show ask questions the mailbag coming up
another Kingdom we're on the third
episode now and it's sounding really
really cool and you get the left is
tears tumblr another way to hydrate
properly go to daily wire calm we'll be
right back
big announcement in the presidential
race
AOC +3 AOC and the squad are endorsing
senator Bernie Sanders for president
this makes a lot of sense
they are the Socialists they are the
hard leftists Bernie Sanders is the og
socialist he was around st. Petersburg
when he felt there was time for a change
and he I'm almost certain he knew Karl
Marx personally so he's been around for
a long time they have endorsed him it's
a big pickup for Bernie Sanders Tom
Perez the head of the DNC said that AOC
is the future of the Democratic Party
and if she's the future of the
Democratic Party I guess Bernie Sanders
is the future of the Democratic Party
I thought Bernie Sanders was the future
of the 19th century but he's the future
of the Democratic Party it would seem
it's a big win for him it should help
him and some of his lagging poll numbers
against Elizabeth Warren the flip side
of that news is freaking Joe Biden can't
catch a break he had a terrible debate
performance who's falling apart and
Barack Obama won't endorse him now you
might say okay what Obama's just not
making any endorsements this year
no he endorsed Trudeau Barack Obama is
endorsing Justin black-faced Trudeau
wore blackface pretty much every single
day of his life till he was 29 and
that's a slight exaggeration but we've
seen at least three occasions where he
did it
Barack Obama's endorsing that guy by the
way Barack Obama's interfering in
foreign elections isn't that so awful
when foreign governments collude and
interfere and their elections oh no old
on old I never mind it only that only
matters when it's a fictitious storyline
used to attack president Trump in the
2016 election doesn't matter what Obama
does it so Obama is interfering in this
election endorsing Justin Trudeau in
Canada meanwhile not a word about poor
Joe Biden bad news for Biden's campaign
why is Obama really not endorsing I
think it's a self-preservation thing I
think if he felt that oh that Biden
could win would win he would endorse him
but he wants to be on the winning side
he doesn't want to be repudiated by
voters as he was in 2016 with the
election of Trump in 2016 Obama said I'm
on the ballot
if you vote for Trump you're voting
against me and guess what happened Trump
won and I think he doesn't want to be
humiliated again and what it really
means is he doesn't think that Bernie
that Biden is going to win it a little
shocking bit that comes out just before
we get to the mailbag today Kanye West a
perplexing public figure leader of pop
culture who all of a sudden he's one of
the he's played himself off as one of
the most narcissistic people in politics
he said George Bush doesn't care about
black people so he made him a big
leftist hero then Kanye West endorses
Donald Trump hugs him in the Oval Office
Kanye West starts talking about
Christianity very seriously starts
reading the Bible seriously makes an
album now called Jesus's King and Kanye
West was caught on reality TV telling
his wife Kim Kardashian that she needs
to dress more modestly because she's his
wife and he loves her and she's part of
his soul and when he does that when she
does that it hurts his soul I count
myself in the Blessed few Americans who
have never seen an episode of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians but I might start
watching is this clip is really really
good for the culture who's Kanye West
horses like there's no underwear is hot
for who and say that you're not into a
corset I just went through this
transition where from being a rapper
like looking at all these girls and
looking at my wife like oh my girl needs
to be just like the other girl showing a
body off no initial and that and I
didn't realize that that was affecting
like my soul and my spirit as someone
that's married and loved and the father
of like now would about to be four kids
Kim shut that down real quick you built
me up too
like sexy person and confidence and all
this stuff and just because you're on a
journey and you're on your
transformation doesn't mean that I'm in
the right I'm in the same spot with you
this is a tremendous exchange if people
are talking about Kanye West's new
comments on politics and culture and
religion they're speaking about it from
a primarily racial perspective like
blech set and that kind of thing that is
legitimate sure I think even more
exemplary here is Kanye West as a
millennial as a someone someone who
speaks to Millennials and Gen Z and
someone who's pretty young himself Kanye
West is coming out of the same culture
we all came out of increasingly
irreligious increasingly uncultured
increasingly shallow politically and he
is going through a transformation
because he is learning things and he's
he's learning things on every one of
those levels he's learning oh hey maybe
the left isn't really helping the black
community oh maybe the left isn't really
helping anybody oh hey maybe these
conservatives aren't so bad after all
hey maybe Republicans do care about
black people he's learning that and then
he's learning on the metaphysical level
oh maybe life isn't all materialistic
maybe it's not all just about appeasing
appetites and it's not all about a cult
of the self maybe there's a metaphysical
universe in a moral order maybe there's
a God maybe that God has a personality
maybe it's a real person that we can
talk to maybe my relationship with my
wife is not just a kind of sexy lustful
relationship maybe that relationship is
emblematic of something higher maybe the
relationship of Christ to his church
maybe I should privilege modesty over
just this kind of material appetite
satisfaction he says all of that to her
and then her answer is great too because
she said you're going through this
transformation but if I'm not where you
are necessarily maybe I'm a little
behind where you are I love it it's it's
an interaction that the culture is
working out right now and Kanye West is
a little ahead of the curve because
Kanye West has always been a little
ahead of the curve on pop culture that's
why he's probably the leading pop
culture figure in the United States I
think this is a great thing and we can
either react to it by knocking Kanye
West for not really knowing everything
politically and not
really knowing everything spiritually
and getting some things wrong here and
there or we can react to it with
encouragement because Kanye West is
actually asking questions he's curious
he's following ideas with some logical
rigor and he's leading people back from
this brink of cultural destruction
pulling them back a little bit and we
can either criticize him for not doing
it fast enough for well enough or we can
applaud him for doing it at all I think
it's a great thing and I encouraged
Kanye on his journey let's get to the
mailbag first question from Megan hey
Michael my question pertains to Pride
Month and that pride is the worst of the
seven deadly sins I was explaining your
viewpoint to my mom also Patriot and she
said well what about being proud to be
an American is he saying that is
negative and I didn't know how to
respond is there a way that you would
articulate a difference between being a
normal level of proud and pride or do
you consider them the same thing the
pride is excessive love of one's own
excellence so there is a place at which
being proud to be an American gets bad
this would be chauvinism the word
chauvinism actually comes from excessive
love of country it comes from this
figure from the French Revolution
Nicolas cheval who was you know the
every legend you could ever put into a
heroic figure and you know guy guy who
would give everything up for his country
that's the percentage of Nicholas
Siobhan and that chauvinism is this
excessive love of one's own excellence
that's not what most people mean that
when most people talk about being proud
to be an American what they're really
talking about is love of country and
loyalty toward country so that's a good
thing that's a virtue I mean that's
similar to filial piety the love that
you have for your parents is seen in the
love that you have for your country and
sometimes we use the word pride for that
but that's not really what we mean in
the case of the Pride Parade that's a
totally different use of pride that is
the use of pride as we see in the seven
deadly sins that is an excessive love of
the self how do I know that because all
the pride is is about me me me me me
that that but it's not even just gay
pride now it's fat pride skinny pride
this pride that pride it's all about
this radical subjectivism
whatever I want to do is good whatever
appetite I have should be satisfied
whatever feeling I have must be affirmed
whatever whatever Prai I mean pride is
the only word I'm trying to think of
another word for pride
whatever narcissistic tendencies I have
must be affirmed I am beautiful I am
wonderful I am brave I have self-care
I have self-love that's the form of
pride and that is pride in the sense of
the seven deadly sins I actually don't
even use the phrase I'm proud to be an
American it's excusable because it's
alluding to something else but those are
those are very different circumstances
and if the Pride Parade we're
celebrating love and loyalty toward
something objective something outside
the self something outside of one's own
identity and outside of one's own
desires then I could understand that but
until they get rid of that your truth
and my truth and me me me and everything
I do must be affirmed then pride is
clearly in the vicious category not in
the category of love and loyalty from
Aaron mr. Knowles
where do you think the Left would be if
Trump had not been elected with the
Democrats have pushed their agenda to
the point where nearly all 2020
candidates are socialists how much is
the left following their arguments to
their logical conclusions and how much
is Trump derangement syndrome the left
always gets radicalized during
Republican presidencies had this
happened during the Bush presidency just
as much the the left would be where they
are the left would have moved further to
the left
this is far bigger than the question of
Trump just Trump irritate them he does
does he push them a little bit sure but
this has been a trend since the 1960s
when the conservative movement really
came into fruition and moved the
Republican Party to the right and when
the New Left took over the Democratic
Party and moved it to the left this has
been going on for a long time and in
some ways it's to be applauded because
it's people following their ideas to
their logical conclusions or in the case
of to the left they're illogical
conclusions which now denies reality
itself denies the reality of sex denies
the reality of the Constitution
denies denies truth altogether from
Claire who's your favorite monarch in
history and why
oh what a difficult question I would say
Charles Martel Charles Martel who beat
back the invading Muslims at the Battle
of Tours and saved Western civilization
but he technically wasn't a king so I'll
take him off the table if I had to
choose my favorite monarch in history at
least in recent history I would have to
choose Prince Joseph Wenzel who is the
heir to the house of Wittelsbach now you
hear that he's a prince but I say he's a
king because he's the rightful heir to
the throne of England through the
Jacobite line of succession James the
second the last great King of England
was ousted by those damn dirty House of
Commons he was ousted by the Parliament
and then those Dutch interlopers William
and Mary of orange came on over and
began that illegitimate line in England
and this was almost rectified through
the Jacobite risings and Bonnie Prince
Charlie coming from France to Scotland
he was a little foppish though didn't
work out that well so currently the
legitimate King of England is Franz the
Archduke of the Franz the Duke of
Bavaria I think is Archduke or Duke one
of those two and that would pass to his
brother max because max is because Franz
doesn't have any kids so it passed to
max max has a daughter named Sophia and
then finally we get to Prince Joseph
Wenzel our future glorious King of
England aren't you sorry you asked from
Amy based on the current political
climate which Democratic candidate do
you think will take the nomination I
think right now the leading candidate in
the Democratic race is either Oprah or
Michelle Obama or possibly Hillary
Clinton what do I mean by that there was
this poll that came out just the other
day from the Boston Herald it said that
right now Elizabeth Warren is leading in
New Hampshire New Hampshire is a very
important early state Liz Warren has
something like 25% and then Bernie and
Biden have 24 and 23 percent however
Michelle Obama gets into the race
Michelle would have 26 percent Warren
would have 20 percent the other
candidates would be down around 15 what
this shows us that the Democrats are
unsatisfied with their current choices
for president this is why Mike Bloomberg
is considering running this is why
has been floated so many times there is
no clear front-runner right now
technically if you look at the polls
it's Elizabeth Warren she's an
incredibly weak frontrunner Biden is not
actually out of it yet his campaign is
completely falling apart but he's still
got a chance that he could get it this
is anybody's race from Michael do you
believe leftists are genuinely immoral
or do you believe they are amoral thank
you to everyone at The Daily wire for
the messages you send in making a
difference in people's lives
depends on the leftist I think plenty of
conservatives are immoral too if you're
asking about the ideology the ideology
is immoral because in the long run
there's no such thing as a morality you
have to pick a side if you stand in the
middle of the road you're going to get
hit by a truck you are either with us or
against us and so leftism
is an ideology that Stokes Envy I mean
socialism is the gospel of envy and the
creed of ignorance as Winston Churchill
said it's Stokes Envy it celebrates
pride it encourages wrath it discourages
forgiveness and and redemption and grace
it encourages lusts and following one's
own appetites it encourages Clutton II I
mean it actually you actually can check
off all of the seven deadly sins those
are encouraged by leftism so it is an
immoral ideology I gave a speech about
that a yamp one time I think you can
find it somewhere on YouTube does that
mean leftists or immoral no I think they
could just be kind of ignorant of what
they're doing or going along with the
culture it's a very tempting ideology I
would have considered myself a liberal
for parts of my teenage years so I I
have nothing but compassion and empathy
for leftists but they are following an
immoral ideology and ultimately if if
the moral argument doesn't convince you
to abandon it I would I would just look
at the self-interested argument nobody
benefits from following those vices down
to the bottom nobody benefits from
living in a culture of Wrath and misery
where you think half your countrymen are
deplorable and irredeemable that's
that's a misery making recipe so I would
suggest in in self-interest at least
they abandon that and and also they'll
they'll enjoy living in a more morally
coherent eye
style last question Michael I saw your
interview with Peter Benjamin about
transgender regret and I must say bravo
to you and to him for a very insightful
conversation my question is what do you
think is the best approach as a parent
if you have a young child who is
confused even if you have not promoted
these ideals in the home such a good
question as I hope that interview with
Peter Benjamin brought out or displayed
transgenderism meaning gender confusion
gender dysphoria is a real phenomenon
it's a real psychological phenomenon and
it's a serious struggle for people who
have a 40% suicide rate the 40% suicide
rate is not society's fault it's not the
fault of some ideology it's it's the
fault of the psychiatric condition that
affects some estimates say 0.2 some
estimates say 0.6 percent of people so
you have to address this if your child
is experiencing this for instance as you
would any other psychiatric condition as
you would any other health condition
because it can be very serious you
shouldn't just dismiss it or shove it
off and say oh well you're really a boy
don't worry about it you should take
them seriously also just like any other
health condition or like any other
psychiatric condition you shouldn't
indulge fantasy the leftist premise when
the left and they do this constantly in
the press and it's not fair but that's
life they they call me in Shapiro and
every other person who doesn't indulge
fantasy transphobes hateful people who
hate those suffering from gender
dysphoria let me make myself perfectly
clear I believe that I take gender
dysphoria much much much more seriously
than anybody pushing this absolutely
wicked transgender ideology I think that
their premise is fundamentally wrong the
premise of the left is that fantasy is
good in reality is bad and if you live
according to reality that you are
somehow cruel and wicked and if you just
look at the analogy on other mental
health conditions it would be like
telling a schizophrenic that really the
voices from the walls are talking to him
and he really should follow their
dictates it is so profoundly patronize
condescending and contrary to human
flourishing the people who indulge
transgender ideology per se or
committing a very serious wrong they're
committing a sin and they should stop
doing it because it is hurting people
and it is in no way compassionate that's
what we see from transgender regret also
you should take this condition seriously
and you should try to get your child any
help that they can and you should try to
tell them that reality is reality and
you should also use the tools that
modern medicine has available to us in
modern psychiatry and of course the
church of course spiritual discussions
as well that would be my recommendation
for a coherent and compassionate way to
address transgenderism and not the
shallow condescending patronizing
nonsense of those who would indulge
fantasy and gender ideology that's our
show I'm Michael Knowles and I will be
back next week so I hope you have a good
weekend this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy bore
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel white
house key
edited by Danny D'Amico audio is mixed
by Mike core Amina hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation